bonjour alors le château de montpoupon
bien appartient à la même famille depuis
cinq générations sa particularité c'est
qu'il est richement meublé et vous allez
voir il a de nombreux souvenirs
familiaux à l'intérieur il y a aussi un
grand musée de la vénerie
c'est un des quatre musées de la chasse
en france je vous propose de découvrir
tout ça puis on se retrouve juste après
sur son promontoire telle une place
forte entre l'os et montrichard
le château de montpoupon n'a aucun
secret pour son responsable touristique
mathieu bibard qui a commencé ici comme
stagiaire en 2004
donc là on nous allons accéder au
premier étage nous allons monter dans la
chambre du roy qui est vraiment la
chambre emblématique de montpoupon une
des chambres les plus belles du château
très lumineuse avec du mobilier
renaissance je vous invite à monter au
premier étage
la particularité de cette chambre ces
plafonds pas mal italienne sa table à
rallonger son coffre a créé danse
d'origine représentatif du mobilier de
la cour itinérante du début du xvième
siècle
tous les châteaux y avait une chambre
haut de gamme pour accueillir le roi
c'était un peu une obligation
contrepartie pour construire un château
il fallait l'autorisation du roi et si
celui ci était amené à passer dans votre
demeure on devait loger les nourrir
forcément on va loger dans une chambre à
la hauteur du roi en montant au second
étage le visiteur fait un bond dans le
temps
direction le début du 20e siècle et les
appartements privés de la famille de la
mode saint-pierre propriétaire du
château
jusqu'en 2005 solange tu vois j'ai
laissé ici tout est joué quand tu étais
petit
il ne rata lit tellement de souvenirs
solange de la motte saint pierre est un
personnage emblématique de montpoupon
c'est notamment elle qui l'a ouvert au
public en 1960 et vous qu'elle savait
parlait cinq langues
elle a beaucoup voyagé elle a créé la
chambre d'agriculture la société
archéologique de touraine dans lequel
aussi elle était entreprenante même des
gîtes ruraux qu'elle a commencé à créer
dans les années 70 sur le domaine de
bonbons avec les anciennes fermes
elle avait commencé à développer aussi à
montpon des survols en hélicoptère donc
vous imaginez pour l'époque c'était
quand même assez novateur solange de la
mode saint pierre était aussi une
excellente cavalière est une adepte de
la chasse à courre il faut dire que sa
famille possédait un des équipages les
plus importants de france
donc la vénerie implantée à mon profond
depuis plusieurs siècles mais surtout
depuis 1873 à peu près où il ya eu la
création d'un équipage de chasse qui est
l équipage de montpoupon qui a été créée
par emile de la mode saint pierre au
départ l'équipage chasser le chevreuil
et à la fin du 19ème début du 20e siècle
équipes achats sera le sert également de
cette histoire familiale est né le musée
du bonheur et ses 30 salle dédiée à la
chasse à courre et au métier qui
l'entourent il fait partie des quatre
grands musées de la chasse en france
faut pas trop attention
alors nous sommes maintenant avec le
propriétaire du château monsieur
louvencourt qui adore ses chevaux
bonjour alors dites moi c'est ce lieu
qu'est ce que comment vous faites pour
vous en occuper pour financer pour la
restauration comment ça se passe d'abord
je suis à paris pour travailler pour
vivre parce que je ne veux pas vivre sur
mon bouton et tout l'argent qu'on rentre
sur cette propriété sert un payer tous
les frais de cette maison là vous avez
un prochain projet de restauration je
crois un gros projet wii clé la
restauration du châtelet d'entrée parce
qu'il est comme il a subi les outrages
du temps
il est quand même dû xvième siècle de la
renaissance et il est la toiture a quand
même souffert maintenant elle a été
refaite et à peu près 150 ans quel est
le budget de cette restauration et
comment le financer
ça sera au tour de 350000 euros
heureusement on va avoir une aide quand
même de la drac les aides de l'état et
le reste sera on va peut-être demander à
la région et sinon ça sera à la poche
voilà comment on vit ici qu'est ce que
ça vous apporte vivre ici vous pourquoi
vous le gardez ce château le garde parce
que c'est une histoire de famille il
sent le famille et parce que je lai dans
les tripes autrement peut pas le faire
si vous n'avez pas lent et très vous le
faites pas parce que la vie de châtelain
est pas une vie de château croyez moi et
ça fait rêver tout le monde mais les
gens qui n'en ont pas mais quand vous
l'avez c'est pas pareil on voit ça
différemment quand j'arrive ici kiabi
degrés l'hiver où ils m'ont dit quand
ils arrivent ici à 8 degrés l'hiver mans
au bureau de paris le soir c'est pas
très agréable mais on s'y fait moi j'ai
plus jamais la grippe mais voilà c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui à montpon demain
on se retrouve dans le loir-et-cher au
château du rocher c'est le château des
énigmes
c'est pour les enfants et ce sera sur
france 3 à voir